what's in here what's it do and can i
make it from scratch it's the stuff
inside yourself
ingredients you can think of lipstick as
a slightly more complicated crayon
crayons are made of waxes and colors and
lipsticks have waxes and colors in them
too but if you've ever tried drawing on
your face with a crayon you'll find that
it doesn't really work the way you'd
like because crayons are hard because
they need to write on a hard surface
whereas lipsticks have to be soft
because your lips are soft so in
addition to the waxes and colors they
also contain oils and a bunch of other
stuff depending on exactly what type of
lipstick you buy but what i really want
to talk about is the reason you buy
lipstick in the first place and that is
its color
cochineal is a scale insect that feeds
on prickly pear plants and it was used
to make dye in south america hundreds of
years ago now these bugs produce a
chemical called carbonic acid which is
this brilliant red color to get the dye
out of the bugs you kill them
specifically you kill the pregnant
females because that's where the dye is
and it takes about ninety thousand or so
bugs to make one kilogram of dry
cochineal powder today we still use
coach neal to color not just lipsticks
but also foods
look for cochineal extract or
carmine which is made from carminic acid
on an ingredients label so at this point
you might be wondering why do we use
bugs to color food i mean ideally
wouldn't we just make all of our colors
in a lab somewhere actually that is
mostly what happens these days but it
turns out that many of the brilliant
non-white non-black colors are
chemically really hard to make so for
most of human history we've had to rely
on nature to do all the complicated
chemistry of color making for us hence
the grinding up of bugs now once
chemists started being able to make reds
like carmine in a lab the use of bug
juice went way down although it's been
enjoying a bit of a resurgence lately
because people have been asking for all
natural ingredients go figure now if you
look at the ingredients of a lipstick
you'll see that there's usually more
than one color ingredient and typically
these color ingredients are described
both by a regular english name like red
seven lake or by a color index or ci
number and this number can sometimes
tell you more than you'd think like a
secret code so for example any number
starting with seven five that is a
natural color so carbine is seven five
four seven zero any number starting with
seven seven that's an inorganic compound
which is basically something that
doesn't have carbon atoms titanium
dioxide which is white and mixed with
red to make pink lipstick is seven seven
eight nine one and then there's seven
seven four nine one nine two and nine
nine which are all slightly different
versions of
iron oxides also known as rust yup
sometimes the rust red color of your
favorite lipstick is literally rust
so now that we know it's in lipstick and
how it works i'm gonna try and make my
own from scratch using natural
ingredients starting with rust as my
homemade lipstick colorant and i'm going
to use mica for some glitter and shine
now mica comes from granite and other
rocks and this stuff is the best glitter
balm material i have ever seen it gets
everywhere and never comes out so use
that information wisely as for my waxes
i've got beeswax which comes from bees
and paraffin wax which comes from crude
oil as for the oils i've got canola oil
and coconut oil i'm just going to assume
that the rest of the stuff in lipstick
doesn't matter all that much so we'll
see how right or wrong i am
[Music]
okay time to pour this into a lipstick
mold
well so much for that idea
now we let this harden
let's try it
i made a bit of a mess of things but
here's the mold
and i'm just gonna pop it open
[Music]
oh wait wait here it comes
ah
lipstick
okay the moment of truth here we go
[Music]
i have to say that's actually the first
time i've ever done that so
let me uh
get my mirror here and see
oh
oh my god it worked
that's amazing
hey
that is not bad i really sort of
i don't really get
okay so
we did it we
we made lipstick i um
i can't tell though if it's really
glittery
the red the iron definitely worked
but i don't know if it shimmers as much
as i wanted it to um it's possible that
the mica settled to the bottom of the
mold uh while it was still cooling and
the way to fix that would be to use even
more finely divided mica but i would
give this i would give this i would give
this a nine out of ten
eight and a half eight and a half out of
ten so if you guys have ideas on how to
improve this recipe uh let me know in
the comments or hit me up on twitter and
if you have an idea for an episode let
me know as well
[Music]